et maintenant il n'y a qu'une seule
chose qui compte aura-t-on une majorité
absolue dimanche prochain à l'Assemblée
nationale pour agir le reste pardon
c'est du débat d'éditorialistes et de et
de calculer
c'est l'avenir pardon c'est l'avenir de
notre nation qui est en jeu pour pouvoir
agir face à tous les risques d'inflation
les risques de guerre qu'il y a aux
portes de l'Europe ce ne sont pas des
petits sujets et donc on ne va pas
seulement considérer des questions de
dynamique de petit pourcents la
dynamique fait la victoire sur quoi va
se jouer cette offre de Tours dimanche
prochain notre pays veut-il assurer une
majorité forte au président de la
République pour agir ou veut-il faire
confiance à une coalition de
circonstances pour bloquer le pays le
débat il est très simple et d'ailleurs
cette clarification et bienvenue parce
que ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'il y a
un enfumage terrible dans cette
coalition nupes on considère que ce
serait une union des idées soit à peu
près d'accord sur rien ils sont pas
d'accord sur l'Europe ils sont pas
d'accord sur l'écologie sont pas
d'accord sur l'économie sont pas
d'accord sur les retraites maintenant on
va le voir pendant 5 jours tous les du
ensemble nupaise partout dans le pays ce
soit à peu près les trois quarts des
circonscriptions qui sont dans ce cas
vont démontrer non seulement des projets
différents mais surtout une incohérence
totale une instabilité totale et un
risque un risque d'effondrement pour
notre pays avec cette incapacité à avoir
la majorité absolue si c'était le cas
pour nous
[Musique]